what's going on reject nations it's Greg
Alba kid and then John Humphrey over
here so we're going to check out the
data trailer for marbles and humans on
the ABC television series but before we
do that this is a sponsored video we
want to give a shout out to you for the
TV time avid time TV time is this app
that allows you to track the shows you
love and react to the moments that
really move you you can keep track of
all the shows that you're currently
watching all the shows you want to catch
up with and the app will actually let
you know when the next new episodes of
your bookmark shows are coming up you
can leave posts on every single episode
you've seen in the post they consist of
anything from leaving gifts memes you
can leave a full review if you want to
and you can even do video reactions as
well now you can basically kind of
create your own content and then review
and interact with fans talk about your
favorite shows ranked your favorite
characters we've actually spent a lot of
time on there just writing opinion on
different efforts yeah shows we've been
watching it's a really terrific I've
been catching up on all the comic book
shows I applied to catch up on all of
them by the time 2017 is over and each
time I finish a season I like to leave a
comment or a quick little review what I
thought of the season so we've actually
been using the app you could follow us
at the real rejects there's a link in
the description box a lot of people have
already been following us already so
join the community over there and follow
us over there TV times available on
android iphone and on your desktop
computer so there's no excuses no way
not to use it another show I got a
bookmark that on my TV time Adams are
holding human sooner or later the users
are going to find us up here you should
have known this day was coming
[Music]
are we supposed to follow our king and
remain silent ease that however we need
to go to this now we've been hiding here
too long let's go to our rightful home
remnant from the government we were on
earth we would have a glorious planet to
live on fine you're talking about
betraying your brother you're talking
about treason you're going to take it
intention right or wrong dangerous what
I'm talking about is freedom freedom
through all engines are you going to use
your voice and kill your only brother
[Music]
pretty cold sprays evening
will not let anyone for anything song we
will create our destiny nothing
[Music]
[Music]
that looks expensive yes it is I mean I
did some research on this and when you
find Jerry the trailer did cover some of
that over there about how they did shoot
a lot of this with I Maksimir I think
they shot the whole season with IMAX
cameras actually can't wait to watch on
my append it's gonna be great
know the quality still really improves
and it was a lot of times we watch IMAX
on film for the the size but the quality
is exceptionally clear and beautiful so
I would tune in just to see what the
imax color looks like and they are
premiere in the first couple of episodes
at an actual IMAX theater for I think
about two weeks which is pretty neat
that's neat yeah I've heard a lot of
people who are been seeing the footage
for this not liking it a lot okay I'm
not exactly sure what they're seeing and
that makes them hate the footage as much
as it is very different from the source
material like the designs and styling
just the design of the production values
and the action and the effects of stuff
look real good for ABC yeah yeah there's
something there I mean the trailer
doesn't really give you a good sense of
strong character perception I think yeah
sure that I can't really tell who's the
who I'm following Chris yeah I just know
that they're kind of a bunch of these
people in an odd situation together and
one of them is going to end up on earth
but I found out about the shows that
there's the main character is a guy
named Black Bolt play by Ansan mount who
is the king of the attendance and they
their home is it switches a lot but I
believe that their home and the show
takes place on the moon his power he
doesn't speak actually yeah that's like
the whole thing they're talking about it
with his voice and it can like destroy
with just a whisper of his voice so cool
so with the the show rooms were doing of
doing voiceover what they what they're
having the character do is they invented
a type of sign language in order for him
to use so I'm obviously that's cool when
I like writers invent a language for a
type of medium j.r.r tolkien he created
his own system so is this a real
language or this just
I think this have a view fake television
sign language hey I'm like what's the
consistency now like you might not be
able to start picking out terms and
phrases because I don't know ASL II won
real mondrian playing another jealous
angry brother yeah what else do you want
to give the guy what is it with a little
a little less evil yeah a little
slightly more mellow yeah I mean yeah I
won't be as violent or as disturbing or
sexually creepy I imagine I feel like we
might get a little bit more
understanding into who this guy is as
opposed to Ramsey it would just seem
like a really tough guys Knievel's yeah
is bad should get my dad's yeah pretty
much what he seemed like in Game of
Thrones and then here I don't know I
feel like they was humanized them a
little bit more it looks like I mean it
you know you're dealing with the Marvel
Universe III feel like you can't just be
despicable yeah and I don't think we you
can just have a hateable character and
in such a problem on your show like this
I mean this the characters here have
been compared to the likes of like
Marvel having their own type of x-men
this time around any minute Marvel
property yeah but I'm saying that now
that Marvel because this is connected to
the MCU so this would be like the
excellent like thing in the X in the MCU
I got that vibe from this actual I got
sort of an x-men mixed with a little bit
of the guardians yeah extra to really
really well we would see there's that
one shot with the whole family at the
table where I'm like that looks like the
x-men sitting it with a subletter outfit
in the I think the wife of the red hair
in terms of what we're just getting from
the trigger though as a guy who doesn't
have much information on who these
humans are and watching the trailer the
show does just look all right to me it
doesn't exactly look exceptional but it
doesn't look worse than anything else
I've seen from a lot of comic book shows
and that's taking in the whole comic
book shows world in general from agents
of shield to anything that you've seen
on the CW
it looks like I'm sure there's something
in here looks yeah it looks kind of
cheesy little Star Trek s I don't
exactly see what we're all the
generation of heat is coming from when
people are seeing this trailer yeah I'm
kind of I'm kind of right there with you
and
terms of the reception it's like the
designs of stuff are cool like this
looks really a high production value and
the first thing I started wondering is
how long are they going to be able to
keep that up you know because you know
it isn't Network TV or your system is a
bit different and yeah the story itself
I didn't get a great sense for what the
season Ark is going to be like but it
you know it looks fine
well looks fine and cool you know what
looks like Black Bolt is the king of the
Italians and then his brother wants to
overtake and now even now they're being
sent to earth and they're on the run
they're hiding because they've been
betrayed that's at least what I'm
gathered from the trailer for a show
that seems like it's going to be a lot
more bent on action and production value
the action sequences don't look great
but of the fighting that was happening
and the sound effects and the way it was
being edited just looked a little bit I
guess the thing that's missing from this
trailer is it doesn't look special in
any capacity and characters don't look
all that interesting if anything Ramsay
knows about a man's gaze now I could
that make them the good guys a
protagonist don't look intriguing to me
well yeah we spend the most time it
seems like in this trailer with width I
don't know who it's scary anyway with
Ramsay Bolton about we will have a place
to thrive in and I'm mostly just focused
on him you know I've seen a few episodes
here and there of agents of shield and
and that show has never really hooked me
very much I've always watched it when I
was watching it with somebody I've never
really felt the desire to want to watch
it outside of it so I feel like I've
been kind of spoiled by the Netflix
Marvel shows it's like watching Jessica
Jones and daredevil like it's kind of
hard for me to want to jump over to what
ABC can offer me in this arena because
you know yeah it's in the same universe
yes and when you got one part of the
universe it's really dark and gritty and
dusty incredibly special on Netflix and
you got the ABC version which from my
understanding agents of shield gets
really good in the third and fourth
season I've heard especially if you look
at the rod tomatoes capsules they always
it's like it gets better every season my
third and fourth seasons when people
like that's when the show really hits
Mike finds its footing and maybe this
show will take a while to do it too but
right now this show seems to be
capitalizing not on its characters and
we'll make some special therefore the
cap
I'm productionvalue I neck I'm having
and look at all our cool symmetric books
like I will say that I really like the
design work in this as an outsider
that's the thing that's pulling me into
this but there's nothing here that's
hooking it's not like I got it tuned
into the pilot yeah yeah I'm not doing
anything to it swage the worries I have
about this caliber of show and maybe
that's ok the other thing I'm thinking
about is maybe this is made for the
people who don't like the Netflix stuff
as much for whom those shows are maybe a
bit too gritty like watching agents of
shield I can see how that feels a
different void for people and I can see
how this would do that too you know this
is reminiscent of a lot of other Marvel
things I've seen in this trailers and do
anything to make me not think about
x-men and guardians of the galaxy and
agents of shield and stuff like that it
looks neat but I have a feeling that in
20 minutes I'm not going to be ever -
yeah I feel like in front of those shows
that I would enjoy an episode but it's
not going to I don't feel like it'll
hope me enough to be like yeah let's
tune into the whole season yeah exerci
goes Navy see they probably have like 20
forever 70 or something like that yeah
and I mean not that it's a bad struggle
but I've seen this struggle before and
again the the display of the power isn't
really that intriguing to me they needed
a trailer that really features who the
characters are because that's the main
hook anything that's comic-book related
is my production value it's characters
who am I going to be spending 30
episodes within a 24 episodes whatever
it is I don't know well I know a lot of
you guys to check out our videos that
are probably are most likely a lot more
familiar with the details of who the
Inhumans are so watch leave your
comments down I like to hear what you
got that saying tell us what you think
about what you gather from this trailer
it be it looks like [ __ ] to you if it
looks like it's actually going to be
good let us know and leave a meme about
it on TV time yeah that's the saying we
don't mind doing sponsorship for them
because yeah honestly an app that we
actually use a lot beyond our own
benefit just like everybody I've shown
that app to in person has immediately
don't put it aren't using like a
determine at all right well you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell that John Humphrey on
twits an inch and use social media
manager of Blum house and you can also
check out our exclusive
perks and rewards over at patreon as you
got a special blog coming up tomorrow
all for a very specific patron